-President Trump held another
surreal press conference today
to defend
his Supreme Court nominee
after a last-minute Senate deal
to allow an FBI investigation.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
President Trump
is obviously very eager
to talk about anything other
than his historically unpopular
Supreme Court nominee,
Brett Kavanaugh.
Only 35% of Americans believe
Kavanaugh's telling the truth,
and only 34%
support his nomination.
And during the hearing,
it looked like he had
only about 33% support
from his wife.
[ Laughter ]
Although it doesn't surprise me
that this guy is unpopular.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at him.
He looks like the kind of guy
who yells at 6-year-olds,
"You have to have a permit
for this lemonade stand!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And today, Trump held another
surreal press conference
in the rose garden,
ostensibly to discuss
his renegotiated NAFTA deal
with Mexico and Canada,
but as multiple female reporters
tried to ask him
about Kavanaugh,
he shot them down
in super demeaning
and sexist ways.
-Yes, behind you, please.
-Thank you, Mr. President.
Now that you've answered
several questions on trade,
I'd like to turn --
-Don't do that. Don't do --
-Mr. President --
-Excuse me.
Do you have a question on trade?
We'll do one or two
more questions on trade.
-You answered several questions
on trade --
-Okay, don't do that.
That's not nice.
And besides that,
somebody is before you.
Excuse me. Don't do that.
Do you have a question on trade?
-You answered
several questions on trade.
-Do you have a question
on trade?
-My question
is on Judge Kavanaugh.
-Okay, please, yes.
Go ahead, please, sir.
-Just to wrap up...
-You know what?
You've really had enough.
Hey, you've had enough.
Question?
Yeah, go ahead.
Sure.
She's shocked that I picked her.
She's in a state of shock.
-I'm not.
Thank you, Mr. President.
-That's okay.
I know you're not thinking.
You never do.
-I'm sorry?
-No, go ahead.
Go ahead.
-I mean, how much of a sexist
dick can you possibly be?
It's almost like --
Wait. Wait.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's almost like he saw
someone else getting attention
for acting like a maniac on TV
and thought, "I could top that."
[ Laughter ]
Trump offered a lengthy,
rambling defense of Kavanaugh,
and then he questioned the
credibility of one of the women
accusing Kavanaugh
of sexual assault.
-Just to be clear,
should the FBI interview
all three
of Brett Kavanaugh's accusers?
-It wouldn't bother me at all.
Now, it depends.
I don't know all three
of the accusers.
Certainly, I imagine
they're going to interview two.
The third one
I don't know much about,
but it wouldn't
bother me at all.
I mean, I've heard
that the third one has --
I have no idea
if this is true --
has very little credibility.
-Only Trump could say, "I have
no idea if this is true,"
and then question
whether someone else
is telling the truth.
"I heard a rumor
she likes to spread rumors.
Pass it on."
[ Laughter ]
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Trump was asked
about the FBI investigation
into the claims
against Kavanaugh
and whether that investigation
should include what seems like
some pretty obvious lies
about his heavy-drinking past.
Trump again veered off
into a random tangent
about the fact that he
doesn't drink alcohol at all.
-But if he did lie
about his drinking,
does that mean
you'll pull his nomination?
-I don't think he did.
Look, I'm just saying,
I'm not a drinker.
I can honestly say I never had
a beer in my life, okay?
-Right.
-It's one of my
only good traits.
I don't drink.
[ Laughter ]
Whenever they're
looking for something,
I say,
"Never had a glass of alcohol."
I've never had alcohol.
You know, for whatever reason.
Can you imagine if I had
what a mess I'd be?
Would I be --
I'd be the world's worst.
-What's amazing about that joke
is that,
inherent in the premise
is Trump admitting
that he already sucks.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, think about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That joke --
That joke doesn't work
if everyone thinks Trump
is a great president.
He's basically saying, "If you
think I'm an [bleep] now,
imagine if I had a few beers."
[ Laughter ]
"I'd be a [bleep] nightmare."
But Trump had a brief flicker
of self-awareness there,
and then it immediately vanished
as he complained again
about being treated unfairly
by the press.
-I think the press has treated
me unbelievably unfairly.
In fact, when I won,
I said, "The good thing is,
now the press finally gets it.
Now they'll finally
treat me fairly."
They got worse.
They're worse now than ever.
They're loco, but that's okay.
-I know Trump has never
had a beer in his life,
but he talks like a guy
begging the bartender
to give him back his keys.
[ Laughter ]
"I can drive.
You're being loco."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Why?
He's being loco."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump's blood-alcohol level
could be zero,
and the bartender
would still say to him...
-You've had enough.
-In fact,
much like a drunk guy at a bar
who starts telling his buddies
how much he loves them,
Trump decided
to get very personal
at a rally on Saturday
in West Virginia,
where he offered
this bizarre praise
for North Korean dictator
Kim Jong-un.
-I was really being tough,
and so was he.
And we would go back and forth.
And then we fell in love, okay?
No, really.
He wrote me beautiful letters.
And they're great letters.
We fell in love.
-Man, if you'd told me
I would live to witness
a Republican President
telling a crowd in West Virginia
that he was in love
with a North Korean dictator,
I would've said,
"I'm sorry, buddy.
I don't have a dollar,
and this my stop."
[ Laughter ]
Also, I feel like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I really do feel like
it's worth pointing out
that when Trump
first got that beautiful letter
from Kim earlier this year,
he admitted
that he hadn't even read it.
-A letter was given to me
by Kim Jong-un,
and that letter was
a very nice letter.
Oh, would you like to see
what was in that letter.
It was
a very interesting letter.
-No, I didn't.
I haven't seen the letter yet.
I purposely
didn't open the letter.
-Oh, no, dude.
Dude, you didn't
read the letter?
Before you talk about
how in love you are,
you might want
to read the letter.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
But that's the thing.
The thing is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Trump would much rather
talk about his bromance
with Kim Jong-un
than Republicans' handling
of the sexual-assault
allegations against Kavanaugh.
For weeks, Democrats called
for a routine FBI investigation
which Republicans refused,
but then, on Friday,
something dramatic
and unprecedented happened.
Arizona Senator Jeff Flake
announced that he would
vote "yes"
on Kavanaugh's confirmation,
and shortly after
he made that announcement,
he was confronted in an elevator
in the Capitol
by survivors of sexual assault,
courageously explaining their
own personal traumas
and demanding that he explain
his vote to their faces.
Now, Flake was still
a "yes" on Kavanaugh,
but then, during the committee
hearing a few hours later,
Democratic Senator Chris Coons
floated a proposal
for a brief delay to allow
for an FBI investigation,
and then he and Flake
disappeared into a back room
while a bunch of other
Republican Senators
had no idea
what was happening.
-After Democratic Senator Coons
floated his compromise,
Republican Jeff Flake
stood up and walked
from the Republican side
of the dais to the Democratic.
-It all started
with this scene right,
Senator Flake
tapping his colleague
Chris Coons on the shoulder.
-Apparently, at some point
during the course of events,
something came,
up and he left the room.
Something is happening.
We don't know what it is
or what it's going
to end up resulting in.
-And then, the room went silent,
and no one is saying anything,
and you could watch
the grim faces of Lindsey Graham
and Orrin Hatch and
Chuck Grassley sitting there,
helpless,
doing absolutely nothing.
-Yeah, sure, but are those guys'
faces ever not grim?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at them.
They all look like they just got
the wrong order at the deli.
[ Laughter ]
They always look like
they're browsing
the Acorn Stairlift showroom.
[ Laughter ]
This looks like that movie
where some old guys
want to rob a bank
before they die.
[ Laughter ]
You just need --
Oh, there you go, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
I'd watch that On Demand.
[ Applause ]
So, Flake went into a back room
and struck a deal with Democrats
for a one-week delay
in the Kavanaugh vote
to allow
for an FBI investigation.
When he came back out,
he tried to explain the deal
to everyone else.
There were still a lot of
details that were unclear.
Would there actually be
a vote on Flake's proposal?
What exactly would a sufficient
investigation entail?
Instead, the chairman of the
committee, Chuck Grassley,
abruptly shut down the meetings,
citing an obscure rule.
And on a hot mic, you can hear
the other Senators
trying to figure out
what the hell just happened.
-I'm prepared to do it, make
a request to the White House,
to ask the FBI
to do that investigation.
It would be short
and limited in scope,
to the current allegations
that have been made.
-Mr. Chairman --
-But I would just encourage
the Democrats
who we talked to before
to endorse that kind of thing,
that we can then move on.
-Mr. Chairman.
-Because of the two-hour rule,
we're adjourned.
-Oh, my God.
It's like watching
your grandparents
try to operate a parking meter.
[ Laughter ]
-"Did we get here at noon?
When do we have
to put more money in?
It's two hours.
It's a two-hour rule."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"The two-hour rule.
I told you when we parked it."
[ Applause ]
So, the basic outline
of the agreement
was a one-week delay to allow
for an FBI investigation.
Afterwards, South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham
was asked what had happened,
said he wasn't sure.
But he did know one thing --
someone would have
to tell the President.
-What Jeff is saying is,
in the -- is --
makes sense to me.
-Do you think that Murkowski --
-I don't know.
I'm not speaking for Mitch.
I'm just --
I'm gonna talk with Jeff.
And somebody's
got to explain this to Trump,
so I guess that'll be my job.
-Oh, yeah.
Act like you hate it,
Br'er Rabbit.
[ Laughter ]
"Somebody's
got to judge this pie contest.
I guess I'll have to do it."
[ Laughter ]
You love
being the Trump whisperer,
because it keeps you on
the Sunday-morning talk shows.
If it wasn't for Trump,
the only show you'd be on
is the Food Network's
"Biscuits for One with Lindsey."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Welcome back.
Tonight's guest is no one."
[ Laughter ]
"Just me and you, biscuit."
But then, as we learned more
about the FBI investigation,
the less serious it seems.
It was reported that
the White House
had put strict limits
on who the FBI could talk to
and what they could investigate.
-In fact, the central figures
involved in the alleged assault
weren't even on
the witness list.
-"The New York Times" reports
that the White House
authorized the FBI to interview
just four witnesses.
-The FBI will question a
specific witness list this week,
a list that does not include
Kavanaugh's third accuser,
Julie Swetnick,
or former classmates
who could share details
about Kavanaugh's
college drinking habits
and shed, potentially,
some light on alleged
sexual references
in his high school yearbook.
-Sources telling CNN
Christine Blasey Ford
and Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh
are not on the initial list
given to the FBI
suggesting who
they should interview.
-Okay, if you start out
an investigation by listing
all the things
you're not investigating,
that's not a real investigation.
That's like going
on a trip to Paris
and saying, "I don't want
to see Eiffel Tower,
the Louvre, or Notre Dame.
I'm going from the airport
to the Hard Rock
and back to the airport."
[ Laughter ]
There aren't any --
There's not a single
Sherlock Holmes novel called,
"Sherlock Holmes And The
Actually That's Not Important,
Don't Look at That."
[ Laughter ]
During the hearing last week,
Kavanaugh lied repeatedly
about key details
of his heavy-drinking
high school and college days,
details that have been
contradicted by many
of his classmates.
Now, today, it is reported that
the White House told the FBI
they can interview
anyone they deem necessary.
And, of course, they should.
Not investigating Kavanaugh's
lies or interviewing people
who could corroborate
the allegations against him
would be, in a word...
-Loco.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]